what's up everybody go to
christycomedy.com i'm back on the road
the chrissy theaters everybody hashtag
cte tour has started baby january 22nd
tampa theater this saturday tampa tony
will be there on stage with me he said
he's going to wear short shorts and his
diabetic socks pulled up to his nutsack
so be in tampa at the tampa theater this
saturday january 22nd then january 29th
we're at the borgata that's almost sold
out in atlantic city february 5th
at the beacon theater in new york city
tt jerry's coming on stage she said
she's going to pee on the front row so
wear a poncho february 11th the warner
theater washington dc february 12th
homeless pimp's birthday show the
tabernacle theater atlanta georgia and
then we got march uh fourth and fifth in
cleveland and detroit go to
chrisdcomedy.com for tiki wiki's fine
yard city portland seattle everybody's
on there indianapolis philadelphia who
gives a
we're going crazy chris d comedy.com
let's have some fun guys in a couple of
weeks i will be coming to detroit and
pittsburgh february 11th and 12th second
shows were added there so get your
tickets a couple of weeks of the next
week after that february 18th and 19th
i'm at albany at the egg and washington
dc at the capital one hall and then to
close out feb february 26th and 27th we
are in madison at the barrymore and
chicago at the vic we've added second
shows to all of those get tickets right
now at southvolcanocomedy.com
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe
hey hey baby make me feel so fine you
keep me rocking all of the time hey hey
babe you make me feel so grand i feel a
million dollars when you're just in my
hand hey baby your name
[Laughter]
first of all hey babe hi hey babe first
of all i rewind it once red wine when we
need to hang out don't don't nail me to
the wall but what does that last let's
by the way pimp it's one of the earliest
times here go can you go back to that oh
yeah no that's fine that's right the
name of this episode will be money pack
him rizzle upon the
that's the name of this app um
what you'll not get no one's searching
for that what what is it uh rizzler okay
here we go depp is the name of the
band's record label
rizzla is a brand of cigarette papers
used to roll marijuana ganga cigarettes
and it's really a play on the rhyme with
no real significance what how did you
find that i read it up there no but
where did he where'd you find the
explanation to that line was it readily
available
oh [ __ ] monkey monkey pack him
rizzle upon
the sweet depp line i still don't you
explained it and i don't understand it
money pack um rizzle upon what is pawn
cause i said pandaripa but is pawn like
with or and you know like
like what is pawn i don't like two is
you in spanish
can you pull up ub40 because they're
white guys with dreads right i believe
now are they in hot water for
appropriate
probably not because they have stood the
test of t they have
okay on the sweep depth line
so it's on the ripa okay
what is rizzla again
so monkey is that like monkey is that
like drugs
like you ever you know but george
michael monkey on my back
no george michael on the faith album i
know jerome monkey don't stop baby
don't look now there's a monkey on your
back i've had the best now it's time i
had to rest so you think that i don't
want you anymore
i think it's a monkey on my back monkey
on my bed no
another expression that is frequently
used is have a monkey on your back it
means that you are carrying a burden or
a problem yeah that's that i knew but he
in the song he's talking about he's
addicted to drugs that's his monkey now
george michael is not with us anymore
but um
boy george is
yes it's very hard to keep those
concealers i love boy george and george
michaels
george michael well i guess got my
halloween costume you know what it is
boy george michael
that's what it is we're going to go as
we're going to combine them that's nice
yeah that's nice um yeah shout out
george michael died of natural causes
which we've talked about on other
podcasts where if you dive natural cause
i talked about it on this one we talked
about this where it's like it's just
very re because natural cause to me you
have to be 150 years old yeah yeah it's
just all natural causes is not murdered
right that's not could you imagine kane
tanaka 119 years old and god forbid this
happens that she doesn't die of natural
causes like she dies in a plane crash or
something like insane
how the hell wrong place wrong time yeah
shout out to shout out kane um yeah so
so um yeah it's ub40 google them yeah i
want to see what ub40 looks like also
what's what's ub like what's the
significance of the name ub40 yeah what
and are they from england oh you're from
england yeah bruv oh wow i didn't know
that i didn't see them when i went to
england that's that's interesting i
thought i would see them the monkey gets
stroked see this is the thing though
with them
in 1978
so that means when when their songs came
out when they really got popular in what
the early 90s or was it before that i
think what did red red wine i think red
red one was a crossover hit i think i
i'm i'm sure they have other hits they
did the elvis cover of can't help
falling in love wise man and what year
was that
that was probably around the same time
so but we're talking about the early 90s
right yeah so that's insane that they
were doing it for 15 years
you know what i mean like ska band
the ball the band's lineup was stable
for 29 years from march 1979 until
january 2008 when front man ali campbell
left the band followed shortly
thereafter by keyboardist mickey virtue
oh so they're not the same bands anymore
so who are the new who are the members
now look 78 to present which means
they're still touring birmingham by the
way shout out berms can we go to
website i'd like to see them if they're
coming to the united states they tied
the record with the english carbon
madness for the most weeks spent by a
group in the uk singles chart
with 214 weeks
wow
do you guys think uh it must feel good
to leave a band
i think that if you're leaving a band
there must be significant significant
issues going on that it probably does
feel good when you finally leave but
most likely it's probably like what
happens with me like when you leave your
mouth
wow
wow
chaos chaos but you know what i'll say
about decision making i'm a little
buzzed right now you know what i'll say
about decision making
is don't let anybody tell you that
you're being erratic or you're not
making the right choices sometimes you
have to feel it and that means you have
to sometimes make a decision that others
won't like you heard that others won't
like and others will disagree with you
with but you're living in your shoes and
your own skin so you need to feel it and
then if that means the decision you made
previously without feeling it was
actually the right one then you go back
to the right decision even if it meant
breaking even if it meant hey it took me
i basically had to let the bird free
yeah to know that that was that's what
it was and then i had i had to get the
bird back the bird came back to his cage
and that's what true love was and that's
what cause you're only gonna go around
this blue planet one time in the
topsy-turvy world so i'm saying all that
to say because you know what that's
called babe
life
life i made a mistake
and now i'm trying to correct it you
know shout out don julio seven shut up
because you make a mistake here's what
happens folks you make a mistake and
then a lot of people are too scared to
correct a mistake because they're
embarrassed about what people are going
to think because they said oh but you
you said you want to do this now you're
doing that you're all over the place
it's called living it's called living
and the truth of the situation is nobody
really gives a [ __ ] about you that's
right you give a [ __ ] about you you're
the only one you're the only one you can
count on that's it my daughter told me
to re-hire the old guy
it's lacroix raspberry
lacroix raspberry if you're putting
something in it and it feels good man i
i wonder who ub40s manager is
how much of this stuff is arable please
have me babe i always have you and
listen the only thing that helps an
imbalance is yogurt chobani yogurt live
in active cultures live in active
culture what about what about
i got hey babe we never did that did we
ever do that
look at this thing that pimp just pulled
up as sales slump world's largest condom
maker will start making medical gloves
well good news for us is we don't use
condoms never have never will what is it
what's the last time you put on a condom
truthfully if you don't mind sharing
what's the last time you put one on i
don't know
like truly i don't know 15 years ago
um
yep i i really don't know because i've
well
i don't know because i'm i've been long
terms no that's what i'm saying so like
there's been no reason for it yeah
pretty much i haven't put on a condom
in
10 years
right right
all right yeah
[Laughter]
got it maybe not 10 years
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're on your own
condom and i think i've told you this
point i know sometimes we don't get
sexual on the show but i told you i've
never
i told you i've never i've never had
anal
i don't think you've ever told me that
no i've never done anal once in my life
ever i've never had anything
not
it does seem relatively easy in the
films doesn't it yeah but i've never
done it oh [ __ ] man
that cracker i've never done i've never
talked about that
like you remember the long conversation
we had about that
i've never i've never done anything my
glasses are fogging up heterosexual anal
intercourse is not an uncommon behavior
with 36 percent of women and 44 of men
25 to 44 in the us reporting ever having
h.a.i
in their lifetime heterosexual anal
intercourse that's fun that's a fun term
to just use in the throes in the throes
of passion down for hai h and it's funny
because hai in japanese means
but in japanese it's like a it looks
like a thing but it it here it's in
american it's heterosexual anal
intercourse it is what is
the sound you make when it's happening
maybe that's where the job maybe that's
where it came from
yeah
it is hard to not say
where did you where did you get topic
don julio
what is going on this has been hey babe
yeah
um nearly half of straight oh my god
yeah nearly half of straight men have
had anal sex well i'm in the half that
has it and you know listen
uh even if you're listening with the
kids i don't i'm not we're not gonna
curse and use foul language but it's
something to be talked about with them
well just because i wish my family
talked to me about it oh look at that
burt crush's twitter what do you know
another promo
[Laughter]
oh sorry sorry um
sal's done half this episode with the
microphone on the floor
um oh [ __ ] so so um
i'm coming
oh god how funny is that wow i love clay
aiken's new look look at clay aiken the
former american idol contestant speaking
of anal sex speaking anal sex
said that he has he's running for
congress in north carolina
right there wow he's nearly
unrecognizable he's not a fashionista
he's only 43 years old is his hair white
now it's white and he's wearing a plaid
tuxedo
oh i love it he's a loud and proud
democrat well yes and clay aiken he's
running for congress in north carolina i
hope
i hope he gets one i don't remember clay
aiken song do you remember
oh invisible that was a i don't really
remember it but i remember that i voted
his year he beat reuben started the
velvet teddy bear i'm sorry for two
thousand four four oh is that what it is
isn't that ruben said it's a big song
what did reuben center invent you said
the teddy bear no no what did you say
his nickname was the velvet teddy bear
right you know
you don't know i was just saying mel
tormey
the velvet fog the velvet fog you know
melton is an old singer
um we in one of our shows i believe it
was in cincinnati it was a dead ringer
for taylor hicks it was a guy right in
the front yeah there was a there was a
97 year old woman that looked just like
taylor hicks did when he was 29 years
old on american idol did you did you did
you used to watch and vote
for america because i remember who i
voted for
oh who'd you vote for god season one i
didn't vote
did you vote no season one i don't even
think i watched i i caught on in season
two and i think clay was season two who
was season one kelly clarkson and uh the
kid with the person justin is who i
voted for i voted for the kid with the
perm yeah i mean with a perm like that
you got my photo but kelly clarkson was
the winner of season one was the winner
of season two reuben stutter
it was clay i thought it was oh no wait
you're right reuben stuttered beat clay
aiken apologies let's do american idol
uh winners american idol winners i i'm
lost after i mean i stopped lost it's
like the first few but i did vote for
taylor hicks and i did vote for bo
who go go up a little bit who's the
america oh i'm sorry you got it i voted
for fantasia go all the way down to one
just go to david cook i remember him go
to the first season okay
kelly clarkson beat what was his name
can you scroll down a little bit it's
gonna be something
i think guarini yeah
good [ __ ] pimp
okay yeah so that's one shout out kylie
clarkson she always has stuff on her
show she kelly clarkson is great i love
kelly's so nice yeah reuben stutter
number two
now so far kelly clarkson is the best
winner of american idol she's huge yeah
she's she maintained i there's one other
huge a lot of them maintain and some in
the top 10 like uh jennifer uh hudson
yeah she's she's like academy award
nominated now she didn't win fantasia
barino is who i who i voted for because
i remember not watching the show and i
was like oh i was like i'm gonna vote
for a fellow italian yeah she was a wild
card marino yeah yeah that's harry
underwood that's the one that's major
wait carry under what i'd argue might be
even a bigger star as big of a star as
kelly i think she's got it as far as now
i think kelly clarkson is more of a
personality now maybe a host and she's
still making
legitimacy i think she's like the
country legend i think i don't know i
don't know much about his one i thought
taylor hicks lost oh he did win i didn't
realize taylor do you know scroll down
look at his hair he was 29 years old
when he won i mean he looks a lot older
but good for him he i remember he did a
version of living in the city
jordan sparks was a big one too oh yeah
it was her father was in the nfl yes
yeah
yes um
david cook i vaguely remember is david
cook the one who's the lead singer of
queen now one of them's the lead singer
adam lambert lambert who's also american
idol he won at some other time chris
allen i don't remember i think i stopped
after seven yeah me too because i
remember david cook who's this i don't
know why i don't know i heard of him
let's go up these are all people we can
get on the pod never heard of scotty
mccreery sounds like a sounds like a
like a like a seamless it looks like he
looks like the guy from mad magazine
scotty mccreary let's see if you know
any of these season 11 phillip phillips
this is it's become a joke
yeah i don't know who that is i don't
know who that is yeah he's from foreign
huge no season 12 kansas
let's go but they're shouting out verbo
caleb johnson season 13 winner caleb
johnson i mean
he came to rock he came to rock let's
see let's see he's 14. nick fradini
freddie annie um season 15 trent harmon
these these names are all sound fake
yeah
maddie pope
16 season 16. i don't know any of these
people lane
the ratings must have plummeted hardy
season 18 is just sam just sam
oh and it was remote
chase beckham season 19 looks like
brendan schaub he that's a country guy
chase beckham if i ever heard one so
that's where they are right now season
19. the ratings must have not well just
television i mean if they put this on
they got to change something about
american idol maybe put on the tube
remember that kid chicken little was one
that you could vote for he was from long
island yes yeah yes
david something i thought pete davidson
performs with jack harlow at la concert
oh je i love jack harlow love jack carlo
it's what's popping brand new whips just
popping it's crazy to see pete up there
performing rap though
i love it
at that point is it more like karaoke
though right now i think it's cool yeah
no i mean it's like
pretty cool like i would i would do this
at karaoke so i guess what would i do
with him we did this on your cruise
pretty much yeah this would actually be
great i'd love sal to go up and do the
same thing so i would kill it on that
when i when i would see you do karaoke
when you would do the um
when i needed to i'd love to see that
yeah pete looked good he looked he had
the moves down and everything nice he's
good he looks good on stage he knew all
the lyrics yeah imagine he got up there
and he was like yeah
i like it i like it um
yeah dude i um i i've seen pete dance in
a way he's almost like i never seen him
really move in a way that was
that tr uh like we're going to be with
him you and i are going to be with him
at the patrice o'neill benefit which
probably is happening it happened two
days ago by the time this comes out
it happened two days ago january 18th it
was great great time the benefit is a
good cause
i started vomiting on the front row it
was a whole it was don julio again me
and sal went out we got trash we lit
derose's bar on fire
uh i forgot it that's 7 30. it happened
it happened but it was a great show it's
in a week it was a great great show the
mayor showed up matteo lane's on it
mateo boss yeah i'm trying to think of a
beautiful body uh uh
still
of course uh yeah i'm forgetting
everybody who's on it i don't know um
but um but yeah i uh i i you know
i feel like
by the way we were talking about um the
other day uh last episode we were
talking about uh succession yeah
macaulay culkin's little brother kieran
kieran called me i think he's earned his
name bro
kieran culkin he'll always be he's like
he's literally like winning everyone
he's like mccall he called his little
brother yeah and mcauley's last like you
know yeah that's [ __ ] funny call i
had the same birthday as macaulay culkin
august 26th you know imagine you have
the same birthday as karen culkin that'd
be wild pull it up pull it up kieran
culkin's birthday may 7th is what i'm
guessing oh i guess
uh september 25th
okay uh september thirtieth night
september 25th wow i mean dude within
five days that odds are not not good not
good the fact that i'm older than
macaulay culkin's little brother is wild
he's 39 babe i'm 37. you're not older
i'm younger
sorry about that
don julio
babe draftkings i've talked about it i
love it you know now if you can just if
you bet new customers if you bet just
five dollars on any nba i know what
you're gonna say what you could win up
to a hundred and fifty dollars in money
to wager with i thought did you know
that because i use it and we shout them
out all the time and i think it's just a
great great opportunity to make money
from five dollars yeah what what five
dollars do you know the math on that
five turning into 150
is
i think it's three thousand percent yes
it's a three thousand percent increase i
think if i'm doing quick math listen
draftking is the best um and if you
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use the promo code hey babe
that's just five dollars on nba and the
nba team and win 150 in free bets if
they're victorious i mean what it's
literally just go do it it's fun it's
fun yeah makes it fun and draftkings
giving all new customers a free shot at
millions of dollars in total prizes with
their first deposit here's the thing
though you got to be 21 or older if you
live in new jersey indiana or
pennsylvania new customers only minimum
of five dollar deposit plus a one dollar
wage required one per customer
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler yeah no one to fold
them all right here we go baby this
podcast of course sponsored by better
help you know it you know what it is
they assess your needs better helps in
the game with us every week they're
going to match you with your own
professional licensed therapist there's
a broad range of expertise available
which may not be locally available in
these areas services available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule any time of the week it's just
really been great it's been helpful and
right now you're going to get a great
discount all our listeners if you go to
betterhelp.com hey babe that's
betterhelp.com you're going to get 10
off your first month ten percent off
your first month at betterhelp.com hey
babe we're all we all need the mental
health help of us yeah i mean look
sometimes you're just sitting there and
you're like i don't wanna i don't know
who to talk to right now i don't know
who to vent to i don't have anyone to
call you just want an outlet i've been
drinking don julio by myself since high
noon today yeah i need someone to talk
to him and that person is at
betterhelp.com
hey babe okay you can send the messages
no sexy stuff just talk to them that's
it lacroix but does his character pro
what just listen
the show is
can you give me one tidbit of success
i'll give you one tidbit of yellow stuff
okay you know this thing do you do this
thing where like you get a new pair of
sneakers and you go yep this is my
favorite pair of sneakers i ever had yes
and it might be because a little bit
because it's just so new and so fresh to
you or you get a haircut you're like oh
man this might be one of the best
haircuts i ever had i'm watching
succession and i think it is maybe the
best show i've ever seen
but i can't slight shows like breaking
bad sopranos the wire the wire
so i just don't know if it's just very
of the times but dude
it is
it is the best show i'm not telling you
something you don't know but it's a
triple it's the writing directing and
acting dude there is it's dialogue and
character driven and i sit on the edge
of my seat like i'm watching a thriller
kieran culkin
is
healing it in that show did he win
awards for that show i don't know but
jeremy strong who plays kendall yes i
just recently read a great article about
him in the new yorker he was an unknown
before that right now he was well he
wasn't known like he was he was in a lot
of movies he's a character actor and he
had pretty big roles like there was some
big movies i went and looked that he was
in prior that i saw that i didn't
recognize him from
but he i read a huge new yorker article
uh that came out about his process that
he's one of those guys that lives it
okay and so he's like hard to they say
it's like could be challenging to work
with him on set because he like
dives into the character he doesn't talk
to people he he carries that mood around
he really uh like
assumes the the role of the character
yeah because so far right now because
because now just just he won't do
rehearsals he won't do rehearsals yeah
that's what i read yeah why because he
just wants it out the first time on
scene oh i guess yeah does jeremy strong
though in succession does he like is
there a wild progression with him
because right now he seems like i feel
bad for him yeah that'll continue you'll
feel bad for him throughout the whole
show ups and downs and stuff like that
but the way he embodies that character
of that like
i don't know and it's still going on
right so layered the the show is so oh
yeah season um
three just aired and ended right and
it's it's as good as ever so because
because so far i've seen three episodes
of succession and all three have been
amazing like edge of my seat like you
said dialogue and it just kieran
culkin's character is just like
wild
did you see
not giving anything away did you see
kendall
uh at his father's birthday yet
at his father's birthday he had a big
event no i saw kendall i saw ken he's in
a baseball jersey no that is okay all
right that's a great a great moment from
season one right um did you oh yes i did
wait wait when they say that when they
take helicopters to the field
he performs at his dad's birthday what
do you mean performs he he raps no i
haven't seen that then
no
dude season three i mean
i i wish i could watch it with you for
the first time
it is it's crazy because we're at season
three and all these charac it's the same
cast it's the same case and i'll tell
you something usually there's like oh i
like him he's my favorite i like him
first of all they're all terrible people
which is kind of odd to put
yourself in i don't know who the you
know everybody's a piece of [ __ ] for a
different reason they're terrible people
but you like watch it and you you had to
empathize with them a little bit i guess
but well when i just found out that
it's modeled loosely after like the
murdock family from fox is that what it
is yeah oh i think i think loosely based
on the last thing that i saw was george
the really is his name george the really
tall guy what's his name greg greg
cousin greg cousin grace braun shout out
nicholas braun shout out nicholas so
good cc everyone's favorite because i
had saw snl episode a few months ago and
nicholas braun was on and i was missing
all the jokes like you've been in
everything ever yeah
and you're wearing a suit that looks
like greg from session it got a huge pop
and i was like what are they talking
about i never seen him ever in anything
yeah but now to see him in this i'm like
oh my god this guy but i just saw the
part where he basically told the one of
the last scenes is at
when uh logan roy comes back
and says i'm coming back and basically
he's a snake and telling the lawyer
everything where the bodies are buried
from the other woman's husband and it's
like a whole thing yeah well
dude i think he's a snake or not a snake
cousin
greg it's it's tbd he really walks a
line look he's by association he's a
snake and his motivations are sometimes
pure and sometimes just beneficial to
himself but he plays it with such a
sweet aloof yes type of thing that it's
and he's he's actually one of the main
like comedic
elements of the show
so he's just he's just a favorite of
everybody dude you are going to be
calling me
you are going to get into this thing i
know it's the it's the show for you yeah
i'm telling you that you are going to
eat this show up i'm telling you is it
better than billions with the answer
i feel terrible to say
starring dan soder
shout out to ann soder the star of
billions i have never seen it i've never
seen the bill i watched one clip that
big j was in have you seen billions
pimpy
uh no no i've never seen billions but
ladies
said it's great she said it's you gotta
pay attention it's not as good as
success to your lady oh i didn't ask i i
know she loves succession so maybe not
but she said it's great she said i
should start it i love it when i was
searching for a new one she said
billions it's just i haven't come around
to it is there anything that you would
like to know about yellowstone about a
progression of a character anything you
want to know that i can just give you a
tidbit as you gave me just a tidbit of
success she's not giving nothing away
yellowstone also i think is comprised of
people that are not the best types of
people right and
the family dynamic and power dynamic
there's some parallels similar to
success which is wild it's almost like
yellowstone is you might have said this
to me but it feels like a a combination
of succession and like sopranos not like
surprises i said it was the sopranos if
it was in montana okay
what i'll tell you it's not that what
i'll tell you about yellowstone is
you're in season one of yellowstone
season two episode six season two do not
like the daughter
i actually don't like any of that right
you've in a way like kevin costner is
just like this he's kevin cosby he's
he's your whole life he's still kevin
costner so you're like i hope he's all
right what i will tell you about beth
beth is is the daughter's name
is you're gonna find out a reason why
she's so angry at life and i think
you'll find
some uh apathy towards her sure for what
she's i know what she i know one of the
major tragedies she went through which
was what i saw that
flashback well it had to do with a horse
that's and a family and a family member
that's a little bit where it's like you
know
your mama died so why okay your mama got
senpai horse what are you gonna do like
[ __ ] like that compared to what her
actual tragedy is oh so this is
something oh you could come at me saying
my mama died on a horse to be revealed
oh [ __ ] because okay
okay well props to the actress because
she plays right in a way that i'm like
you know what's mind-blowing to me about
these actors and actresses succession
yellowstone you google them they're all
from england and australia they nail
accents and dialects from the
intricacies of new york and montana
neighborhoods where i'm like i can't do
that sing it sister
talk about it all the time preach
because it's preached
no no because no because it is one of
the things i harp on all the time i
cannot believe
everybody you see that first interview
with them and they're like
yeah beth is from england beth's from
england yeah she's from england so is
you know who's from england um okay uh
uh
uh shiv's uh
husband uh oh tom tom
england yep oh my god i know
shiv what a name her name is siobhan
siobhan is one of the most wild names in
the world because it's spelled
s-i-o-b-a-n yeah i don't know what
they're asking us to do with those
letters it's not what they're saying
talking about can i tell you something
also she australian chevy's australia
okay why british actors act so much
better than american actors well i mean
that's debatable but let's
um
they're often better than american
actors debatable because they grew up
with shakespeare from day one and they
grow up with a lot of poetry in their
lives actor martin freeman the hobbit
you know who he is i know who he is i
did a movie with the office is where i
went but yeah but i know from did i ever
tell you i told you when i did the movie
with them right what happened no sir
okay just real quick and then we'll get
back i did a movie with him it was
called ode to joy it's one of my only
movie roles my role was called staten
island knucklehead that was wrong ode to
joy christos stefano you can maybe chris
stefano scene whatever
ode to joy knuckle chris stefano staten
island meathead sorry are you kidding me
yeah this is the only movie i ever did
in my life in
was russell webb in this russell webb
was not martin freeman was in this and
your friend i'm sorry not your friend
he's friends with andrew santino jake
something he's an actor comedic actor
but gyllenhaal
no not the snake roberts um
jake something but ode to joy um
was
is there a clip
you had a scene with him i had a scene
how did you get a movie role they they
it was one i didn't even audition the
casting director who cast a show called
benders that i was in the only tv show i
ever really did benders was the cast
director of this jake lacy uh was a
casting director for this and said i got
a roll for you are you available on this
date so what i needed to do was we're
running on in the bqe uh if you're not
from new york on the beach there's a
place called the promenade it's
beautiful promenade looks over the bqe
brooklyn queens expressway and you can
see a gorgeous view of manhattan
so so um uh oh marina baccarin's in it
yeah i've never met her she's from um um
um the dark knight and all that no no
she but she's from uh you watched it
with carrie matheson and oh uh uh uh
homeland isn't she
the
wife yeah she's just opening scenes yes
she is she's the wife of the redhead
guy from billions yeah um also not
american yeah damien uh hearst no
something damien something but open to
joy yeah damian lemon um shout out d
lemon but um he's also english you know
damian lemon no damien
the guy from the other guy the guy from
billions the redheaded billions yeah
yeah he also blew my balls off when he
smoked dan soda's from england too
so oh to joy so what happened was i got
yelled at by the director because i
might actually my scene might quickly
have been in the trailer too it's i'm
jogging past him so what the scene is is
i'm jogging past him
and he says
to me i jog he's in a funk and i'm
because the premise of the movie is he
can't remember things he has like
amnesia where he can't remember anything
yeah it's a comedy he's actually a
really good movie
how how wild is this you ready for this
let me just tell this quick and then i
promise i'll get to the point but this
is the the only movie i've ever been in
in my entire life
there for a i'm talking about the
smallest of scenes there was a um uh
when my when me and jasmine weren't
together for a little while we were
co-parenting she got another boyfriend
the very first date he took her to see
this movie because all the other [ __ ]
sold out you're [ __ ] me the only
scene i've ever been in a movie isn't
that your ex-boyfriend and she was like
yeah i had no idea she was like oh my
god i was like that had to suck because
she was like what the [ __ ] like you took
me that's
the same because it was her idea to see
this movie because everything else was
stolen she just wanted to see movement
it was just she was like it was
completely he said no but he was like
what the [ __ ] so
you're obsessed with this guy i was like
she is we've had a second child since
then but uh
but um but that's neither here nor there
um but but but ode to joy so what they
that's my scene by the way that that
scene to the right when he's on the
phone on the promenade that's my scene
with him so
i i we're jogging by my apartment yeah
and i bump him and he's goes what the f
man and i'm like watch where you're
going and then
he goes
we get into an argument we get into like
some type of struggle and i have to
throw him
off the promenade no yes and it was like
crazy to watch special effects like
dangling and how it makes it all look
but the the the
the director because it was a movie you
could curse whatever he goes just improv
improv a couple of lines you know when
you throw him off like something you
know so i go you know throw him off i'm
like oh you know get over here whatever
and then he goes all right you know like
something he goes something you know
whatever that this is the scene that
that was the scene like it's it's i'm
i'm like i had just hit him
so
so i go um i go uh
one of the takes i go um i go i throw
him over and it was the acting was
perfect he had said leading up to it was
like this scene they were gonna use
until i ruined it because i throw him
off the go and i go [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
hobbit no
no he was the leader he was like you
can't yell the other movie he was to
start and martin freeman was dangling
off the promenade dying laughing no he
was like did you just call me the hobbit
i was like yeah i was just in private
lines he was like i hope they keep that
one and the director was like can i talk
to you for a second like
like you know he brought me over he goes
hey what the [ __ ] and then yeah so so he
was a good sport about it he was great
dude he was talking to me martin freeman
absolutely nobody freaking loser never
even acting was literally being like
beyond cool like beyond cool i had i was
did one scene on one day of this movie
they've been filming this movie for
months was so cool so nice was like oh
maybe i'll check you out at the comedy
cellar you know like just like make no
mistake i'm going to watch this tonight
oh i'm looking for your scene tonight oh
it's a joy it's it's towards the end of
the movie so if you want to but it is
but i wouldn't even advise fast forward
i i actually enjoyed the movie and and
and uh you know there's many things that
i've done that i didn't enjoy at all but
but ode to joy was it's just a cool
movie did you see morena bacaran though
no she wasn't on set only me
jake is his name
i think he was in girls he's a great guy
great great guy too and martin freeman
she's got a
um marina background has a very uh gal
gadot feel to her yes very gal gadoish
sure but you were you were gonna you
were talking about something else here
martin freeman oh we didn't we get into
this question i was talking about martin
i was talking about british people we
were talking about accents okay um i
said what did i say let me let me ask
you this though we might have talked
about this a little bit benders
that was a television show that you were
a main character on
you shot 10 episodes 10 episodes
you had no prior television experience
zero
what was that like like were you
[ __ ] your pants every day or because
you knew schultz and because you knew a
couple people was it like so low rent
that it wasn't that you didn't have fear
or were you like oh my god they're gonna
have action and i better be good so how
did you memorize lines did you do
rehearsals so here's when i were you in
the mirror at home saying your lines did
you understand
what did you try to act like a character
or are you just yourself saying the
lines i need to know everything
everything how you got cast you
auditioned what
please tell me so but it's just so crazy
because this is the only thing i've ever
done and i don't even remember filming
this like i have zero memories of any of
filming any of this what the days were
like nothing so what was the show what
was the idea of the show so the show is
called benders it did one season on ifc
it's now on netflix you could see it
benders and the premise was a you know
new york hockey team like just a you
know a hockey team like not real hockey
players like playing in a men's league
hockey uh thing it's just our story of
you know kind of our relationships and
what it is my character's name was
anthony so it was not that much of a
stretch to play
uh me but the actual
day of the very first rehearsal the very
first read-through script read-through
of the one and only acting job i've ever
gotten in my entire life that i was the
co-lead of was the exact day my very
first child was born no my daughter
delilah was born on may 19 2015 at 10 04
in the morning you [ __ ] coincidences the
table read for benders the very first
one of my very first acting job ever
started at may 19th at 10 a.m i showed
up to the table read by 1 30 p.m they
broke for lunch still with placenta on
my shirt because jasmine delilah's
mother had said just go to the table
read i need to take a nap anyway just go
to the table so i went the ve
my daughter was five days old every day
because we filmed an entire 10 season 10
episode season of a show in 30 days
because they had a low budget in 30 days
seven days from
june from from may 24th to june 24th
which is coincidentally the birth of my
second daughter violet was born on june
24th but from may 24 to june 24th we
filmed
every stay seven days a week for 14
hours so the entire first month of my
brand new daughter's life i was there
only at the night time i still had tags
on her brain still attacks just like the
sweatshirt oh yeah that scene too we
filmed with the guy he had a main part
on breaking bad he played he played the
guy in the wheelchair all right if
you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month if you feel like
you're in a never-ending cycle of debt
with no end in sight upstart can help
you make that final payment so you can
get ahead
rather than looking at your credit score
alone what upstart does they consider
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smart array for your loan find out
how at upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com do not
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information providing
your loan application upstart.com
hey babe lower your monthly payments
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating your high interest
debt funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between a thousand up to fifty
thousand dollars
hey babe you can even receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan loan amounts will determine
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application baby america's number one
meal kit you know what it
is who's there hello
hello you know who it is this hello
friend america's number one millionaire
yeah we love hello
hello fresh first of all they deliver
pre-portioned and green ingredients to
your door including farm fresh produce
that arrives within a week you get
convenience stop skimping on quality
skip the trip to the grocery store
seriously after the grocery store i'm
going hello fresh they cut back on time
spent in the kitchen so you can spend it
on your other resolutions that you spend
speaking of resolutions the new year is
a great time to focus on what's most
important to you kids yes whether it's
saving money or ordering less takeout
learning to cook or prioritizing your
wellness hellofresh is here to help with
endless options to make cooking at home
simple and enjoyable you know what they
have
dunkaroos
they have dunkaroo cookie dough
vanilla delight cheesecake
[Laughter]
dunkaroo cookie no
it's 72 cheaper than a restaurant meal
of the same quality that's more money to
put towards your 2022 goals i'm telling
you and it's like they're giving it away
listen to this deal hellofresh.com
hey babe16 that's what you need to go to
go to hellofresh.com
hey babe 16 and use the code hey babe
16. you're going to get 16 free meals
plus three gifts i free gifts i cooked
the hibachi uh it was like sweet and
sour
shrimp yeah
i feel because seafood is a little
tricky yeah i don't cook well seafood's
a whole nother deal i cooked it i
actually felt like i did something with
my life oh it's awesome hellofresh is
it's it's great i've been using it me
and my family use it the kids eat it my
kids eat it it's great hellofresh.com
hey babe16
free 16 free meals plus three free gifts
that's a gift for every wise man
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit what was your least favorite part of
a tv show
the hours i didn't like the hours i
hated having to do every scene over and
over and over again from a million
different angles i think what you get
actually in comedy with um you know what
we do in podcasting and the internet and
tv stuff is we do it one time the most
organic time that's where the communist
to try to recreate moment after moment
felt so artificial and was very
difficult for me to break through take
me back you auditioned i auditioned just
okay open calls only you auditioned you
got callbacks you had to full audition
callbacks i got i got uh uh somebody
actually remember
sent me i forgot who
maybe i forgot i'm now i'm forgetting
who sent me a dm on twitter like a
fellow comic was like hey i just
auditioned for this part of anthony in
the show coming out on ifc called
benders you just seemed like you'd be
perfect for it so i sent it to my agent
at the time they got me in and lo and
behold the creator of it was apostle
productions dennis leary's production
company shout out jim serpal shout out
tom saletti they were my first managers
i ever had in my comedy career i had no
idea and i get do the audition you know
it went i guess well got the call you're
nervous for the audition did you
memorize the lines did you play opposite
someone or did you slate the camera take
me through it later to camera audition
just me in the room with the casting
director i'll never forget i was pacing
up and down broadway and prince street
where the casting office was pacing up
and down
the line doing the lines over and over
and over again just auditioning doing
the lines as a matter of fact the actual
audition the audition was i think in
april
whatever the audition yeah jasmine's
birthday is april 17th
on her birthday april 17th on her
birthday this is crazy on her birthday
this is the call back like what again
we're getting so close i had an audition
at 12 noon
jasmine comes with me on april 17th
because our plan was going to do the
audition at 12 or one o'clock whatever
it was and then go have lunch in the
city for her birthday or dinner in the
city for a birthday the actual audition
i'm talking about i'm standing outside
the building with her i'm like just wait
in the lobby i'll be up come back down
she goes i think my water's about to
break its time she goes i think i'm
going to have this baby april 17th on
her birthday on her actual birthday i'm
like jess i got to do the audition she's
like
you need to call we need to go get to a
hospital i'm feeling the baby low low
low
and i remember having that thing where i
was just like
how like because she had already had a
child before she was like it feels like
the baby
so i said what am i supposed to do yeah
and i said it's important for me to
maybe get this audition for the baby so
she goes
she goes okay
go do the audition if i'm not here in
the lobby i went to the hospital i'll
text you so now i'm going up with panic
saying i might go do this audition and
miss the birth of my very first child
i go do the audition
felt like i had a great audition jim
serpico and tom slater like stay awhile
we're gonna have a drink
after and now i'm like oh no what do i
do do i pick the birth of my first child
or do i have a drink with a kid with a
with a producer who i may or may not got
the show drum roll three hours later i'm
still drinking with jim
no no i said to him the situation he
goes oh go i go downstairs jasmine's
there she goes the pain went away she
goes i think i had a little bit of gas
from shish kebab from the sugar bomb we
ate at the cool cause she's pregnant
she's having cravings
so
so i remember then i was getting a call
about two weeks later i get a call
here's a little inside info thing with
with entertainment
if you get a call
and your manager a if you're if their
assistant is on the phone and says
please hold i have your manager your
agent your lawyer everybody's on the
phone that's either really great news or
you're in big big big trouble i've
gotten both calls
um
one a little bit more recent so i take a
deep breath right before that deep
breath and i said okay and i never
forget i get on the phone
and uh my manager at the time shout out
conan smith great guy he goes um he goes
hey is this anthony you know and i was
like and i was like uh i was like no i i
thought i genuinely thought like maybe
it was for another kind of goes no i go
no no it's chris to stefano he goes no
this is anthony i'm talking anthony and
i was like i still wasn't getting it
and i was just like no it's chris
he goes no this is anthony from benders
you're anthony and i was like wow i got
it it was like a whole big thing
whatever whatever and it was like crazy
thing my lawyer jeff cohen who's chunk
from the goonies we've mentioned before
was like this is great like big thing
awesome yeah and then uh it got one
season got cancelled immediately okay
but that's just the ups and downs so now
what happens now you go and you do
wardrobe
testing to whatever now they send you
scripts in advance how long do you have
a script in hand before you're shooting
that script i will tell you
me and andrew schultz andrew schultz and
i
went to andrew schultz's apartment in
downtown manhattan every day for
two three weeks okay before that first
table read where my daughter was born
every day we went there and practiced i
will tell you
by the time the table read came when the
day my daughter was born i knew
everybody's lines including my own
same thing when i did for the one
episode for that one episode the same
thing with the cbs pilot i knew
everybody's lines i could do verbatim
verbatim at that time i could look out
just just by repetition that's andrew
schultz's brother by the way this video
is actually strange i found here what is
what what's going on with schultz do you
guys do something for the show no what
is this is this on schultz's youtube
oh yeah they had to shave his eyebrows
for the show
he had to do that for the show
they couldn't just put latex over him
well no i think they did oh okay but you
see this is the thing with with with
schultzy this is 2014 15 and he was
doing this [ __ ] way before it was cool
oh yeah you know yeah i know see but you
know what's so crazy is i don't even i
remember none of this which is bizarre
because
i'm just not present enough like i need
to meditate and find a way to really dig
deep and find a way to be present
because i
just am not like how do i not remember
that like i don't remember a second of
that it's the only television show i've
ever been a part of that's wild do you
or do you remember almost every episode
of joker no not at all at all i didn't i
don't remember most i remember like big
moments sometimes like it'll come on the
television and i look at it and i say
sami's having zero recollection okay so
it's not
i don't know man i don't know how it
because there's things in my life i just
i guess you just forget them do you
think that's weird pimp that i don't
remember that i mean not really i think
like my friends who work in offices
start to just blend the years together
too yeah right i think when you're just
busy it just kind of all blends together
yeah but this is one big moment in time
i mean it was six years i mean eve look
at this bender's new ifs here's a
thousand views but let me ask you a
question so then you would get a script
and then what you'd practice at home and
then you get on set and would was there
any nerves or did you adjust to the
lifestyle quickly there was i need to
this is the info that the the the
viewers want to know there was i'm going
to barbara walters shout out
there was there was because everybody
was crushing it i never had i had no
acting experience i had worked with an
acting coach shout out ted stabierski
great guy now how did you get him
i hired him ted saber did you find him
uh i believe through the production
company they're like there's only two
guys ted sliberski and another guy
both are so you got krakow the two big
acting coaches in new york are ted
zabeerski or bob krakow these are the
guys bob krakow i the cbs gave me when i
did my cbs pilot ted spears guy i did
with ben what happens you meet with him
you call him up he says i'm gonna hire
you yep he gives you his rate and then
you go meet with him
and then well no both of them are
production company paid for okay so oh
so you're like i i'm i'm new at this i'm
green will you get me there or they they
got it for you they got it for me but
they told you we're gonna get you an
action yes both great styles both
completely different and how much time
do you spend with the acting coach i
spent and with ted i want to say i spent
an hour to two hours a day
for like a week for a week or two bob i
only went to two or three times and did
you feel the benefits of it yes and what
are some things that he would tell you
is it technique is it actually how to
act is it the business of acting and
what you're expected to know and do ted
ted sobierski it was just always ted and
i right we would do a thing where it was
always
was it your scripts yes no no no he only
worked me on benders okay it was a lot
of things where he you know would be up
on our feet it would be you know
doing other people's lines it would be
like just consuming the character bob
was more about from what the thing he
worked me like with the cbs pilot the
co-star of it was diane guerrero shout
out today andrea great great lady great
actress
she he made us
like go shopping together go to a movie
together like make believe
like do that he was like forma for real
bonds right like you know obviously you
know you both with other people so not
all but form a bond right because it
comes off on camera and he was right it
really did like you formed that bond
better yeah well you're like i would you
actually get like upset when you're
acting when she's like rejecting me when
i'm like that hurts like i got broken up
within real life that's how you have to
do it now granted the cbs pilot didn't
go and everyone at cbs said the reason
why one of the main reasons didn't go
because chris isn't a good actor but
that's neither here nor there um
but uh oh oh
birth control um
so so so you're there and you're you're
doing the lines he's like well what what
he's asking you questions like how do
you think you'd be feeling the scene how
do you think you'd approach it why would
you say it that way can you take it this
way can you do it this way if i'm gonna
be 100 with you again and it's getting a
little scary i actually don't remember
much at all from any of the acting
coaches experience okay but you remember
that you did glean yes stuff from it
when you applied it but i remember
because you asked me was there pressure
yes there was because at by the time we
were on day five day five so i'm brand
new day five cinco they had emailed the
producers had emailed my agent or called
my agent or manager and my manager
called me said what's going on with you
on set oh no and i said what do you mean
and they said you're the only one of the
main four that seems to be really
struggling
he said you know did you think that or
did you think you're doing fine at that
point i did think that and feel that
because i was the only one that was ever
like cut let's do that again or i'd be
taken out of the room by the director
like hey like you know and it was a
director because each person would
direct a different episode shout out
this guy richie keane richie keane was a
director
dickie keane he said to me because i was
struggling he was real cool to me he
said
i think what you're doing is
you're
you're playing this he i forgot exactly
what he said but he goes
your character anthony he goes think
about anthony
thinks about hockey like sex
hockey is a is a woman that he wants to
have sex with so every time you're
talking about hockey you're thinking
about hoppy hockey make believe you're
having sex with the hockey stick that's
what and it all clicked in my brain for
some reason next thing you know i'm
[ __ ] lubing that hockey stick right
up my ass every single time
something's changed something genuinely
you felt like you then all of a sudden
you weren't yelling cut you weren't yeah
like you you had purpose i remember
there was a scene uh a funeral scene one
of uh jim norton did a guest role and he
he dies in the first episode of cancer
he's like the new guy and then he dies
of cancer and there's a seed where he's
in the coffin right
and is it really him laying in the
coffin it's him laying in the coffin and
he's just he's great jim norton and he
goes um
and we're doing this scene in the
funeral home and he goes uh and and and
it's not good and jim you know the one
of the producers towards the side he
goes do you not want to do this like and
who to me and i genuinely thought like i
was i had heard the lines rehearsed i
was in the moment he goes do you not
want to do this like what are you not
understanding so i was like
confused who said that to you one of the
producers i don't want to give his name
one of the producers said that to me
right in front of everybody no he's
pulled me aside okay he goes like do you
not want to do this and i and it made my
anxiety go to 50. he did it because
because my manager had said they're
thinking about replacing you okay like
that's how bad i was doing i had no idea
until richie keane told me make hockey
look like sex dicky keen dicky keen so i
go back over there and jim who's his
whole scene was just to be in the coffin
like he was just dead in the coffin and
we were having dialogue over you knew
him at this point i knew him and he goes
um and you know while they were setting
up the shot he was like you know just
like sleeping in the you know his eyes
goes to the carpet open his eyes he goes
listen he goes [ __ ] everybody on the set
you're the comic you know what's funny
just do exactly what you do if this was
a comedy stage [ __ ] them all they're not
funny you are and then i did like an
improv line and then he killed him
in ladies then he closed his eyes and
went back to that he feels like a
cartoon deaf like he was like that and
then he go and then i remember i don't
remember the exact lines i did but
whatever the i improv something and i
started to improv and tag and just be
silly and make it more me and then from
then on and then i i genuinely and they
said that they this they said this to me
i'm not saying this about myself they
said the producers then said by the last
day the last day of rapping they said
you went from worse to first they said
you became the best actor on this entire
set even steve sharipa was like you
really like are nailing this part so he
was like keep keep going whatever you're
finding and acting keep going haven't
gotten one roll since then except my cbs
pilot canceled immediately
this has been a baby
haven't gone one roll since then but wow
i'm happy for the experience so were you
just nervous to
to
just nervous to take your own liberties
like like and to improvise and to to
just really like to throw caution to the
wind were you just reserved i had zero
confidence right because i thought i'm
not supposed to be here right my
you know i'm not i i i got this job as a
fluke i got this job because
one of the producers used to be my
ex-manager all this [ __ ] that cloud
in my head
but then i just said you know what
you're so good on i've seen scenes and
you know i saw a scene of you you did a
a thing with soda and michelle wolf
about all these cars yeah yeah i thought
that scene was hysterical yeah that's
you with friends improvising and they
let me in profit yeah yeah so now i know
when i act and when i every time i do an
audition anytime i get the opportunity
to act in anything i always i l i ask
for forgiveness now i and not permission
i i just improv i say let me put my spin
on let that's another thing i learned on
that set of benders is let the director
tell you scale it back
always go out go out with whatever it is
let them tell you hey stick to the lines
no harm no value stick to the lines but
they may not they may say that was an
angle i didn't think of so recently i
was on i did what we do in the shadows
right and i was so ner it was a very
just like four or five lines and they
were very straightforward but i so
wanted to improvise and i kind of didn't
until like the very end i i improvised a
few lines but then i didn't say anything
and i was like i could have done this
the whole time right like i was going
into their world i was in the house with
every every every one of the characters
right and i was like i'm just supposed
to come here and they do what they do
and i just deliver my lines right and i
was so nervous so i just did my lines
but like in the end i threw in a little
and then when i realized i did it a
couple of times and it was funnier and
they respond to it and no one said
anything i'm like [ __ ] i could have been
doing this the whole time full time yeah
so i i just learned that so again but
you know now you know i i've done that i
know that every audition i do that
haven't gotten even i mean a smidge of a
callback i mean it's an immediate note
for me all the time who's it's not an
immediate note for that was tom brady
that's yes he won the super bowl in
tampa bay on the box which is
unbelievable yeah and it's not enough
for
gotta be honest patrick mahomes and the
whole organization of the kansas city
chiefs you know they should walk out of
that stadium with their heads held high
because they're a young team and they
made it to the show babe and they have a
bright future ahead of them and it's led
by mahomes how could you say no to
patrick mahomes green he's got booger
green eyes light booger greens
it's what everybody wants lbgs hope lbg
a lot of people want to talk about rbg i
want to talk about lbg light booger
green ice yeah i got a big story about
rbg i used to this has been hey babe
don't run um from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey